hi i'm alex and this is my recipe for a
giant peanut butter cup so peanut butter
cups are one of my all-time favorite
candies so naturally i wanted to make a
giant this recipe is super super simple
so don't be intimidated by its size just
be excited by its size because it's a
giant peanut butter cup so to start
we're going to melt down some milk
chocolate chocolate is chocolate it's
going to be delicious whether or not you
temper it and i poured that into the
bottom of this tart shell pan so you're
just going to spread that out nicely
with a spoon or spatula and you want to
make sure that you're going up the sides
of the pan you also want to make sure
that you're doing this pretty evenly
because if you have any like holes or
gaps or whatever you just don't want
them
then you're gonna pop that in the
refrigerator to set now we're gonna go
on to the filling so peanut butter cups
obviously don't just have peanut butter
filling fun fact it's kind of like a
fluffier crumblier texture so i'm trying
to emulate that i mixed peanut butter
and i mixed up peanut butter with
powdered sugar and butter do you prefer
chunky or creamy peanut butter
i prefer creamy peanut butter for sure
so once the bottom shell of the
chocolate has cooled and set gonna pour
that peanut butter filling we just made
right onto there and spread that out
nice and evenly then of course we're
gonna top that with some more melted
chocolate and spread that out evenly
[Music]
and then pop it back in the fridge
finally set so if you want to make this
recipe i highly recommend getting
yourself one of these tart shell pans
that pops out just gonna make your life
a lot easier if you only have like a
regular tart pan you could just still go
for it it'll still be delicious so then
like i said you want this tart shell pan
because you can literally just pop up
the bottom and serve that's literally
all you have to do for this giant peanut
butter cup it's so easy but so delicious
i serve this kind of like
a cake again because
i mean you could just take a big bite
out of it and eat the whole thing but if
you want to share cut a big slice and
ate it like that but again you could
literally just bite out of it take a
bite do you
and if you make this let me know i want
to see it slide into my dms gotta stop
saying that a lot of times when i've
made giant foods they've turned out to
be a giant
mess
but this one was really simple
and
obviously delicious if you want to see
me make more giant foods you can always
subscribe to my youtube channel i don't
know how that correlates but you can
try and make it i have to do a pun every
time
giant
you either get a pond or song that's all
i got
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you